[Music]
let's go out to uh the youth to the Salt
Lake City to the SLC talk to Randy
what's up
Randy thank you Dr deloney for taking my
call of course man what's up so my wife
and I have been married for over 23
years we've got three adult children one
is married to are off to college and uh
over the last several years I've had
suspicious
of multiple Affairs but she kept my wife
kept telling me Oh it's all in your head
it's in your head well recently I did
find out for as a fact with proof that
she has had an affair with a with a
woman her friend okay and she has
decided to move out and and abandon us
and move out with her new girlfriend or
slash wife okay what do I I
mean talk about a shock right no
what how do you how do
you how do you go through something like
this and then what what's the next step
when you find out that that that
somebody that you've been with for over
23 years has just thrown that all way
and and not just any throw it away but
throw it away and go live with another
woman yeah I I think the
um I don't want to let
the who
um or even what um I don't want that to
make this more complex than it already
is so I don't want you to get hung up on
she's with my best friend she's with
some random guy from work or she's with
another woman I I think that's a
distraction from the core
issue the core issue is your wife said I
don't love you anymore I love somebody
else I'm
out and I think it's easy to find a
bunch of other things I'm going to be
mad at my buddy I'm going to be so angry
at you know dating apps I'm going to be
mad that she's with a woman and now
she's telling me she's gay what I think
that's a distraction from you feeling
the depths of hell that you have been
cast
into okay and so I think healing or
you're not at the healing Point yet I
think grieving dealing with the reality
of this is step
one
often Almost 100% of the time when I
have this conversation with somebody
that somebody of shortterm somebody of
we've been married for 10 years we've
been married for 20
years often there is the initial shock
and awe and anger and frustration that
happens but often the most
catastrophic
loss is not the person leaving it's that
Randy you knew for a long time something
wasn't
right and now all of a sudden the person
you trust less than her is you lost
trust in Randy and it makes it hard to
know what to eat it makes it hard to
know what to time to get out of bed it
makes it hard to know what to say to
your
kids because suddenly the most confident
person you were in the world suddenly
you don't trust that guy
either is that
true uh most of it I I I trust myself um
I and I I'm strong enough person to know
okay what it is and and I need to take
care of myself and continue if not for
myself for my kids nope for you for
taking care of your kids is taking care
of yourself okay so so taking care of
myself but losing trust in others yes um
yeah it's it's definitely hard to trust
anyone at this point yeah so when she
said she's gone what does that mean is
she filing for
divorce she yes she she left so I filed
okay um she she decided to yeah she had
her whole family come over along with
her girlfriend and pack up all personal
his stuff um and and took off okay so as
hard as this is right now from this
point forward because of her
declaration this marriage this
partnership this best friend you thought
you had now this is a business
transaction okay and as much as you
allow your um and we treat we treat our
business partners
fair I don't want
to I don't want to take advantage of
somebody who buys one of my books I want
my book to be a gift for them in
exchange for their 20 bucks okay so
we're going into a business transaction
doesn't mean that you dishonor her you
try to rip her off off I'm going to get
the most money for I don't do that with
my customers and I don't want you to do
that with her and I also don't say ah
you know what you don't have to pay like
I have some some costs in this book
right I wrote it I took a year of my
life to do that away from my friends
away from my family away from other
business opportunities I got paper cost
we've got publishing cost it costs money
it's a business right sure and so we are
now in a business
transaction and I want to tell you this
is
awful I hate it for
you I hate it for you I hate the
conversations you have to have with your
kids hate the conversations you have to
have with your friends everybody's going
to have an
opinion everybody's GNA give you stupid
advice and dumb advice well it's just
it's just and dude at the end of the day
it's you laying in your bed in a quiet
house
heartbroken
right yeah
how the conversations been with your
kids they're they're angry yeah to know
that their their mom you know just left
and and not not just left but said you
know I I've got the lawyer and we're
going to destroy you is her words
exactly
yeah what what what is what is her vitol
against you why does she suddenly want
to destroy you
because I found out the
truth I don't I don't understand it
sounds like she's getting exactly what
she
wants that's that's my thought too
that's why it's so confusing she's she's
getting everything she wants um and and
but yet because I find out the truth you
know she wanted to live both
lives wanted to live a double life you
pop the balloon of her little fantasy
where she could have you your secur
and your stability and your financial
resources but she could go have this
loving sexual relationship on the side
and just run a double life right uhuh
yeah yep and I you know I've seen that
with with her web searches you know how
to how to live a double life good gosh
all this it's like are you kidding me
she didn't even clear search history my
goodness dude oh her her search history
is is a mess of of don't know what I
should say on the on the
show dude that's just like cheating 101
clear your search history right I mean
geez well even if you even if you clear
your web searches there there's ways
recover people think we're we're
searching in secret uh people know
everybody know that's right so um so for
her to do that I mean her web searches
and I've got all that documented sure uh
show that she's been searching not only
just you how to live a double life but
uh how to become more lesbian yeah how
to become how you know how to address it
how to what do you do with other women
uh how just on and on and and kind of
really gross uh stuff and then text
messages between the two of them I've
I've seen uh and even even more gross
just so yeah it's it's really disgusting
and so here's what I would recommend you
do I would this going to sound
crazy you know there's been infidelity
you know your wife looked you in the eye
and said I want out you know her family
is with
her and they have
moved the more you go Swan diving into
the details into the sorted photos into
the
whatever the more you're choosing to go
mad have you hired an attorney
yes great I have this is what you pay an
attorney
for every time you think
through I wonder if at this party and I
wonder about this and I wonder about
this other woman and this other guy and
every time you do that you're choosing
misery you've hired an assassin let your
assassin do his or her
job you get about healing and every time
if you do the Cannonball back into the
sewage the sewer water you're choosing
misery don't do that and dude by the way
I know it's
hard
also let your kids be angry and you
don't fall into the Trap of talking crap
about their mom
okay that will be very very hard to
do but your kids know in their core that
faults in
all they are half their their mom and
they are half their
dad and if you start trashing mom now
there's a reality mom chose to leave Mom
made some hard decisions kids I'm
heartbroken that's not y'all's job to
fix but your old man is really really
sad and confused and
heartbroken they don't need to know
about what was on the computer they
don't need to know about the photos and
the texts and all that
stuff it's okay to say yeah mom mom left
she got a girlfriend and her family
moved her out and I'm heartbroken
that's okay but she's a this and I can't
believe that don't do that to those kids
okay you do need to have a space for
that and that's your close male buddies
I'm hoping you've got a couple do you
have
any I I do yeah okay yeah I want you to
make it a priority to meet with them
once a week in person if at all
possible and I want you to preface this
with guys I'm coming up on a hard season
I'm gonna be sad for a while I need you
guys
and I know that sounds awkward and weird
and very unmanly but that's the path
forward for
right but if you get together and just
talk crap about your wife or talk crap
about what you found or talk crap about
her family or lawyer talk crap about gay
people if you do that you're choosing to
cannonball into the
sewage that's not grief that is
wallow
yeah the grief is you feeling how
freaking quiet your house is at night
now and putting your hand on your chest
and
weeping or get to talking about your
buddies and once your anger starts to
subside a little bit you're able to have
sorrow in front of other guys and say
the words I really miss
her and I got to build something new now
I did not see this
coming
that's
grief and unfortunately that's the only
path forward where you're going to be
well and healthy and
whole does that make
sense yeah I'd hug you if you're were
here I appreciate it it's it's it's just
something you don't yeah you you can't
see you don't expect right that's right
that's right you got hit in the mouth
yes
and so this is a business transaction I
wouldn't talk to her anymore she chose
to leave I wouldn't send text messages
anymore every message she sends to you I
would just let it go into The Ether you
don't have to deal with um sharing
custody of kids or anything like that
your kids are
grown yeah yeah thank goodness yeah and
so you don't have to deal with that
you're GNA want to know what she's doing
you're going to want to know how she's
doing you're going to want to know all
that stuff's normal you spent 25 years
years with her including dating right
yeah yeah that's a quarter of a century
how old are
you 46 okay you've been with her longer
than you haven't been right yeah yeah
it's going to be hard to breathe once
you stop being so pissed
off and that's right because she took
one of your lungs with
her she took your hands and your legs
cuz y'all were one y'all are a
gang
so you're going to have to learn how to
do everything over
again and I wouldn't wish that on my
worst
enemy because everybody deserves
somebody to come home that they can drop
their shoulders and just be
safe and this my friend I'm being
intentional here this is grief this is
sitting in it the reality of it okay not
getting distracted by all the other
stuff
but moving forward dude I wouldn't go
down the search history anymore you got
what you've given give everything over
to the attorney and move on I wouldn't
go through those text messages again and
again and
again I just
wouldn't I wouldn't let anybody talk bad
about my wife I wouldn't let anybody
talk bad about the gay community I
wouldn't let anybody talk it just
doesn't serve any purpose at
all the truth is your wife left you
there may be some truth that when it
comes out she's like I've been telling
you for years this or you are struggling
with why or what whatever and there may
be some truth to some things you need to
work on moving forward in your life
Maybe not maybe you just got sucker
punched on this
one make sure you take care of yourself
sleep when you can but also honor when
you're going to wake up at 2 am for six
months get a have a
book
have a video have something to
watch and just honor your body it's
trying to reconcile how to breathe only
one lung for a
while you'll grow another one but right
now you just got one because she took
one it's going to be hard to walk
because she took one of your legs y'all
were y'all were won for a quarter of a
century make sure you eat right when you
can make sure you hang out with your
friends make sure you at least walk
around the neighborhood this would be a
great time to start lifting weights if
and get a trainer if you don't have one
let your lawyer do their
job it's a business transaction now I'm
heartbroken for you brother hang on the
line I'm going to send you a copy of
building a non-anxious life I don't know
if you're in the mood for reading but
this will be a road map to start
building something back and to honor
your body as it rattles and Shakes as it
figures out what to do
now hey go ahead and put on your past on
there too what happens when you life
hits you in the mouth and you got to f
figure out what to do
next we love you buddy holler if I can
never help
man